[Music]
warbats originally called titanos nozuki
are giant flying serpent-like dai kaiju
created by legendary
pictures that were first seen in
godzilla versus scoring the trailer
the trailer introduced a never-ending
conflict between two titans of the
legendary monsterverse
the shots or scenes of kong fighting at
least two warbats is both thrilling
and eyebrow-raising because it feels
like it's just a brief glimpse into a
much
bigger part of gong's story so what
exactly is a warbat
and why is it such a big deal that this
kaiju character
is in godzilla vs kong warbats are
winged snake-like monsters that will
appear in legendary pictures 2021 film
godzilla vs gong
playmates toy company first reveal
legendary monsters
describes them as venom bring it
monsters that hunt the hidden depths of
the hollow earth
robots can use their wing-like hoods to
fly however their speed and aerial
capabilities are yet to be revealed
the warbat's original name was nazuki as
revealed
on an early leaked packaging for the
playmates figure
they are hollow earth dwelling monsters
that resemble giant cobras or serpents
with long thin bodies and gray brown
skin they possess several
reddish flaps of flesh around their
midsection which spiral out
around their bodies and connect to large
wings i'm guessing that there are a
couple of monsters that have inspired
the sky juice design
one of which is the king cobra from the
animated godzilla series
which was a mutated nemesis of godzilla
junior it was also a giant snake with a
frill and sharp spines
another monster that might have
influenced the warbass design is the
face hugger
from the alien franchise you know the
ones that latch onto the mouth of people
and forcibly lay the xenomorph x within
them
the warbats were first presumed to be
quetzalcoatl among fans they shared some
resemblance with the king cobra from
godzilla the series
nuzuki was renamed to warbat due to
nozuki being too hard for a child to
remember
when they were first seen they had the
name nozuki and it is not certain if or
clear if warbat is now the creature's
official name
due to toy companies normally renaming
figures to something that is easier for
a child to remember
and also since the target audience is of
course american the name warbat would be
more badass
packaging for the kong action figure
revealed that the eighth one of the
world will wield a battle axe
in his upcoming confrontation with
godzilla we have also seen kong fighting
at least two warbats in the hollow earth
lifting one and slamming into another
the choice and the trailer have also
confirmed that comb will be much larger
in size in godzilla
versus kong than he was in kong skull
island
when kong was only 104 feet tall back
then
so how big exactly is this warbat and
godzilla vs kong
as we have seen kong while fighting with
godzilla on top of an aircraft carrier
he is more or less the same height as
godzilla
2019 godzilla is about 393 feet tall so
kong would also be around that same
scale around 400 feet
when gong smashes the warbat swinging it
towards another
the tail of the warbat from the hands of
corn touches the ground while
kong's hands are just below the chest
when we compare that tail length on
and stretching it half of the robot's
total length
will be equal to kong's height that
means warbat's overall length will come
to around 800 feet
or more however most of the monster vest
islands have not
had their total length or heights
reveals or mars
except for a few we can only assume that
these cobra like titans will be around
the same weight
as godzilla or kong or even more another
big deal about this style and kaiju is
that even though it was generally an
oversight snake
it could actually fly and glide during
the battle kong was swimming one of the
warbats at another
that was flying towards him i guess the
wings that developed from their spines
can actually let them fly pretty well
even though they don't look aerodynamic
at all lastly the sharp spines on the
wings of these islands can secrete a
greenish
liquid which most certainly is a type of
poison that they use to hunt and kill
other creatures
or maybe as a defense mechanism anyway
what are your thoughts on the matter
do you really think that the warbats are
really that big and if not then put your
thoughts down there in the comment
section
so subscribe hit that like button and
also smash that notification bell for
regular updates
take care fam